Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel
x-men video our first legit x-men project in
marvel phase 4 coming to disney plus next year
with a bunch of new episodes so i'll explain
what's going on and what's going on with the new
x-men movie that marvel is still working on in the
background right now too i will be doing episode
videos for this when they start releasing them
be sure to subscribe to get everything we also
have all the marvel super bowl trailers coming
this weekend for doctor strange multiverse of
madness and moon knight maybe a couple other
surprises whatever trailer footage they wind
up releasing of course i'll do videos for it no
worries i know how you feel about it wolverine
but know nothing little man but the big news
you probably saw recently in your feeds in the
x-men teaser marvel released a little while ago
is that the releasing 10 new episodes of x-men
the animated series it's more of a continuation
than an outright sequel series it's only a sequel
in that the events of the new episodes will take
place a good time jump after the original x-men
the animated series finale but you have to imagine
a shinier looking version of the original
animation it'll look the same just shiny hd
4k footage it originally ran for five seasons the
reason why marvel kevin feige are calling it x-men
97 as you probably guessed is because the series
originally ended in september 1997 in real life
some of you younger people watching this video
might not have even been born yet when that
happened don't we all feel old now disney plus and
marvel have started green lighting more and more
animation even some anime series if you can
believe it marvel's what if is the best current
example that i did videos for all those episodes
and they are working on what if season 2 right
now it's also supposed to be released next year
just like the new x-men episodes if you've never
seen x-men the animated series it is one of the
classic all-time great animated comic book shows
just like spider-man the animated series all those
episodes are on disney plus you can watch them all
right now the reason those shows had the same
vibe to them similar animation styles is because
they were both made to be part of fox's animation
block in the 90s fox ordered this massive chunk
of episodes from a bunch of different people
including batman the animated series which was
part of this animation block so all that really
classic iconic animation that everybody remembers
ran at the same time let me know in the comments
if you actually watched those episodes when they
originally aired after school days back in the
90s x-men the animated series was loosely based
on the 90s x-men comic book runs that's why all
the costumes look like the 90s x-men comic book
costumes the 90s were when the x-men comics were
their peak of popularity normally spider-man
batman superman historically were the most popular
characters around the world but during the 90s
the x-men really dominated that's why the original
x-men 2000 movie was viewed as the beginning of
the modern era of comic book movies like the first
big splashy mainstream huge comic book movie blade
technically predated it by a couple years so
it should get some credit but it was rated r
so it wasn't quite as mainstream as the first
x-men movie in the sequels but whereas x-men
the animated series tried to be as faithful as
possible to the look and backstories of all those
characters in the movies hugh jackman for instance
said that brian singer outlawed comic books on the
set so kevin feige actually got his start as an
assistant producer on that first x-men movie this
is baby kevin feige if you can believe it he had
virtually no power at the time so he couldn't go
around tell brian singer the other producers
to make the costumes or the story more comic
book accurate at the time but no joke hugh
jackman did say that kevin feige would sneak
him wolverine comics in his trailer between scenes
just to give him some character references when
he was creating his version of the wolverine
character he had to picture kevin feige sneaking
around the set of that original x-men movie with
a bag of comic books the animated series covered
most of the iconic x-men stories they did a
really long version of the dark phoenix saga
that was basically all of season three they did
a version of age of apocalypse they did a version
of days of future past all much more comic book
accurate than the movie versions of those stories
for those of you that are still sad what
they did to oscar isaac in age of apocalypse
don't worry he's coming back as marvel's
mcu moon knight and it is going to be badass
that's actually going to be the next big disney
plus series to air after the book of boba fett
moon knight will be like our next big thing and
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes but
all the new episodes will look the same as the old
like i said just shinier hd versions and all the
original actors from the original series will be
coming back to do the new episodes if you didn't
watch those episodes just quick recap about how
they ended that show they did a flashback episode
where wolverine tells a story about fighting in
world war ii with captain america before he became
wolverine he was born in the early 1800s and
because of his healing factor he wound up fighting
in pretty much every major war around the world
through vietnam kevin feige actually tried to do
a version of that captain america backstory in the
first captain america movie using hugh jackman in
a james howlett cameo scene where captain america
was rescuing all the pows and howling commandos
because he would have been there fighting with
them in world war ii but fox said no dice at the
time because it was during their peak hugh jackman
wolverine period it was when they were getting
ready to do that x-men origins wolverine movie
the tv show did a version of a mr sinister origin
story flashback to when he was still nathaniel
essex and in the original final episode professor
x is almost killed and lylandra from the shiar
empire comes to rescue him by taking him back
to her planet magneto is on his island jenosha
with an army of the mutant brotherhood getting
ready to conquer the world but the x-men convince
him to stop out of respect for professor x because
he's dying but the final ending scene of the show
was all the main characters going to the x-mansion
saying goodbye to professor xs he and lavandra
leave in her spaceship to go back to the shia home
world and try and save his life and that was it
that was the end of it so the writers the marvel
people said that the first episodes will answer
the question where is professor x after that time
jump in terms of big villains they could bring
back not counting magneto because he's more of
an anti-hero apocalypse the phoenix force and mr
sinister were the biggest villains that they had
on the show they'd already destroyed apocalypse's
celestial ship and destroyed his original body
but they kind of teased that he'd return to
the physical plane to come back after them
the again an elemental balance of power of good
and evil has always denied me final victory
until now cool connection to marvel's eternals
movie that some of you may have realized
in the eternals movie they explain more about
the celestial's cosmic history apocalypse got
all of his advanced tech from the celestials by
striking a bargain with them that's why he has
such advanced hypertech in ancient egypt he's
not a time traveler like king the conqueror
but when they were covering apocalypse's backstory
in the show they did a version of kang they just
called him the bender but it was the immortus
version of kang just from the look of him who
became more of a guardian of the timeline he who
remains kang during the loki series was kind of
like the mcu version of a mortise king king at the
end of his own timeline when he become a little
less evil they could always introduce another
big x-men villains from the comics but it's only
supposed to be one final run of 10 episodes as i
believe so mostly i think they'll just be wrapping
up all the pre-existing story lines with the
major villains that they already have we'll get
a full trailer next year probably around the same
time we get some footage for what if season two
for those of you asking about the live-action
x-men movie that marvel's still working on now
they've been working on it for a little while
the working title is just called the mutants
i'm not crazy about the title but they might wind
up changing it before the movie actually comes out
the reason why they're just calling it the mutants
is because it won't be a carbon copy reboot of the
fox x-men movies it won't be the exact same
path for the way they evolve those characters
but it'll still be very comic book accurate like
a very different looking version of an x-men movie
that is still very comic book accurate based on
the current marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movie
schedule they won't be able to release it till
at least 2025. the closest thing to a mcu x-men
movie we're going to get before that is deadpool
3. there are rumors about other mutants showing up
in other marvel phase 4 movies before that so
we will see mutants in the mcu before they do
a legit x-men movie but as you probably guessed
marvel is using a couple different methods for
explaining mutants in x-men in the mcu multiverse
and mutants being created inside the main mcu
universe doctor strange multiverse of madness
is supposed to have some fox x-men cameo scenes
think of it like spider-man no way home with
all the multiverse explainers tobey mcguire
andrew garfield spider-man versions and their
villains from the multiverse kevin feige didn't
recast new versions of those villains because they
were all so great he said he never even considered
doing green goblin doctor octopus in spider-man
homecoming or spider-man far from home with
different mcu versions of the characters
because he always wanted it to be willem
dafoe and alfred molina and it's going to be the
same thing with some of the fox x-men characters
but a lot of the multiverse x-men versions just
depend on which actors are willing to come back
but everyone post all your theories in the
comments below if some of the x-men come from
the multiverse and some come from inside the
mcu how do you think they'll explain the ones
inside the mcu that have been around this whole
time really important reminder my book of boba
fett episode 7 finale video will post next and
my marvel super bowl trailers will start posting
this weekend be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss those everyone click
here for my brand new marvel daredevil video and
click here for my full moon knight trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!